prettier Livia bought a turtleneck and I
think it's a woman's medium that I don't
know how this is going to work we're
gonna get through thee it doesn't even
have sleeves that's so tight oh my god
today we are going to make a young
child's dream come true today I'm being
transformed into my favorite superhero
Superman
Darkwing Duck Batman Beyond Darkwing
Duck is the best superhero ever because
he is so unique
I watched the show a lot as a kid the
world was so imaginative
I pressed with Superman since I was a
little kid who doesn't want to be a guy
who can fly have superhuman strength
lasers out of your eyes are you kidding
me you name it he can do it and I want
that feels like I have a lot of makeup
on I am afraid to like stretch ages the
best part about the costume is easily
the duckbill I think my face is a human
is kind of a lackluster but if you put a
duck fill on this face it's gonna bring
this whole thing together I'm gonna be
all new sorts of handsome the thing that
about the costume that will make it feel
right is the cape like even as a kid
dressing up in other costumes you put a
cape on and it changes your whole
demeanor you know I remember dressing up
as a kid and the way really felt just so
different I felt like I really could do
anything
I was darkling duck before once for
Halloween and I'm really hoping to beef
it back up because last time I was
dressed up this darkwing duck this time
I'm going to become darkwing duck
I am the terror that flaps in the night
I am darkwing duck Wow I really am done
going duck whoa
my boobs are so high it's ridiculous
right this is making me feel sweaty and
powerful like those two usually don't go
together but this is an instance where
they do I knew it was more handsome with
a duck bone
this is a face that deserves a duck girl
I feel very stealthy I could fight crime
and raw eggs depending on what mood I'm
in there's just such a rush there's a
power the fascination is there modern
mythology their tails are become
American legends and it's fascinating
and it's fun and it's good versus evil
the classic storytelling who doesn't
love that